let's go man we're at Witts Wednesday
but I got some Johnny Walker it's not
our usual Japanese peace with the
economy walk the the shipment came but I
wasn't able to sign for it Swiss Keith
in the mail you have to have someone
over 21 be able to sign for it and no
one at the office so that the UPS so I
do what I could
mmm you know I'm drinking water Oh
before you have some dad daddy stop
drinking at night because you know what
happens when he drinks wine there's a
little bit of Tommy I told you that
yesterday at the park got a little tummy
and also I have my face tends to hold
water I look like a Roswell alien
you know those Roswell aliens looking
like that more floating dead body in the
river
Wow take it easy hmm I mean my face has
never been more swollen either so Who am
I to say the best is um the best is I've
been getting a lot of TMS about starting
my own business and people have ideas
that they want to go into businesses are
always great always good from Ricky
Morty when I run and show Brennan up
this is an idea and I want to start an
app you go brother though I'm like hey
guys I'm not I'm not trying to not
competing I'm not Mountain Bear point
but thank you so much dude start certain
leather belt it's always the worst start
leather belt I make him out of my home
dude we put cattle on the Friendly's
buckles yoursel million of them my
profits only 60% I'll share 40 with
that's what I get I'll share 40 with no
hey no no I had a dream I started to
tell you boy thin boy productions and
for some reason I could alright it had
to be like it had to be five ends it was
such a weird dream I was like oh do try
trademarking something I put on the
lawyer with three week I know well we
try to just remember why I got it done
but with shut up I don't think boy but
think what I could not big deal but the
thing is is it's it's not the way it
looks because I'm like no mines
different cuz there's three Caesar in
the lawyers going it's how you say you
can't copyright or trademark thick
that's in the English language you can't
it has to be unique so that's so you
have three seats three season has to
have a certain logo on it like there's
all this oh okay then I was in the
market I own sick boy calm so there's a
lot but you couldn't have done it
otherwise no wow
just like remember when LeBron tried
trademarking Taco Tuesday and someone
said what's next you [ __ ] happy hour
taco do we can't trademark taco - yeah
you can you can't trade thick boy bike
club though yeah well I mean I feel like
thick as being spelled with three C's
that's not that wasn't enough no it's
not different enough this because it's
though it's the way in the English
language boy you take one word right or
is it two words two words it's funny cuz
I just bought thick boy which is one
word what I hate you know I have all
those I don't all those yeah and then
fake boy copies thick with Tuesday's
dick oh so let's try doing that these
[ __ ] cuts great so much like it
doesn't and people said to me it doesn't
matter it's not if it's not the original
thing it's like buying a knockoff pair
of Jordans yeah you can buy it well
that's a roast USA about this is Chinese
copy a lot of American technology and
stuff like that play catch-up see how it
works it's good you're stealing a lot of
stuff but if we started focusing on it
wait [ __ ] yeah you just keep up come up
with newer and better cool [ __ ]
that's why I guess I ended up writing a
shitload cuz I was so pissed off about
the extension you know of till August
first and I just saw that it's just an
absolutely how mad they write when we
got those I was so nervous
Oh fuming I was fuming because I don't
know how to fight it and people go along
with it and so I then I was like you
know what I'm gonna I have a lot of
answers to this I'm just gonna be
creative and be funny about it and
figure out ways they don't have any
answers you shut your [ __ ] mouth
sheep where's your master sheep we're
[ __ ] math I'm not wearing it you heard
they burst masks what they work look up
the sights with them oh yeah they die
they don't Oh kiss foul cheap it was
like they'd it might make you feel
comfortable they don't know the idea
behind a mask is that you don't give it
to someone else
oh yeah the idea is that you don't know
no I'm giving you that but that doesn't
work chip but that doesn't work it helps
it does it yes does it cuz can you
breathe through it
what the only way we work there's these
super high-level math you can buy so
expensive but if you can breathe out
ones are the ones that can actually
protect you like the n95 that's what
they're saying right you if I walk in
with like a bandana
yeah holiday not have a mask on the eye
yet the underneath part is is is well
the bandanas are just a bit I wear one
because it checks the box because
they're not doing thing but the mask if
you can breathe in and out chin you're
the air you're breathing in the area
breathing out it doesn't do any okay
well you guys get your sources from I'm
not sure where but the ones I was
looking at the South Korean doctors
they're on the front lines that's
different it's different if I am
ninety-five mass and I like the medal
they're saying that even you were I wear
it it helps to not spread it it doesn't
make sure it does I spread it by not
spread by two percent it's doing
something though yes do something two
percent like I feel good trying to do
something I I just when you when you
walk on a beach okay you have to have a
mask on and I know it's gonna do I have
a problem no what no one's gonna do that
I'm not doing it these cut these cuts
are trying to put press all these rules
they don't have they really don't have
that power
yeah they really don't yeah we should
start with we have a guest on today we
got Dave Rubin I met Dave Rubin who I
love doing a lot of research looking
under stuff brilliant man yep
if you're sick of hearing about corona
and paul takes bribe pass on this
podcast yeah it's not our brand a listen
I know you guys hate it as much as you
do I think we're having a Monica's you
and I have some questions we have
questions and also guys just sell this
for a second sell this for a second
because if you don't get involved with
politics about the ready listen if you
don't get involved with politics
politics gets involved with you so we're
gonna ask him basic questions no big
deal maybe just questions about how to
stay in Formula just how to fight this
stuff when you don't agree with
something the rooster revolution maybe
we start a little maskless revolution
you know what I mean the resistance the
high seas or assaults that's it zero
good t-shirt idea for that too low
resistance no somebody left in the
comments that they wanted a through
thick and thin shirt with you both your
bike losses then those were thick and
thin all right three ends lace you kind
of doesn't have been on the signature
you're well
first of all no we make t-shirts that's
a good idea
it's alright through thick and thin yet
dude here's in his it was the thing I
know about merch we're already on 2
August merch Papa you got a plan for
this stuff alright it takes a while to
get it going
yeah know where we attack Oh
but yeah [ __ ] comon I'm singing it too
but the thing is is how about J Schwab
the VP of thick boys bike club saw a big
old saw us check this snake out riding
today and he was really scared I can why
don't you get a videos all I have so
scared eyes turning it looks like a
[ __ ] garter snake chance not a
gardener it's a bits of people's it's in
that's in Denver Colorado actually house
really specific is that it's a bull
snake
oh yeah all snake she go to battle with
R Allison yeah they're not poisonous no
so you technically could grab him yeah
but I probably wouldn't still I would I
would I would secure its head mmm and
then I would detainment yeah sure that's
why you should go meet with the San
Diego Chapter with me tomorrow morning I
shouldn't ride the Santa Santa Cruz
heckler ebikes
I'm gonna demo so those I'm sure there's
Umi snakes out there you can grab I'm
talking all the [ __ ] almost goes for you
grab grab okay I would you know you told
me to do it I'd do it oh I'd love to see
that and I would I bring a small flute
and I arm them I try to kill it though
would we and the problem with charming
snake is that your little your little
trouser snake would get all [ __ ] hard
to look at oh I don't know if you saw
this please don't play it this a so sent
me this video okay well please never go
[Music]
to me yeah mr. chin the bull snake bull
snake yeah that's what people are saying
it is I don't know my snakes but bond
line yep that's kind of looks like yeah
that's what it is right there let's see
you again Jesus Christ
yeah that's him huh yeah we get feels
common well there's actually some funny
concept
yes Maggie's y'all weak grill that [ __ ]
and when when Theo saw that that
rattlesnake gives bear that's a long
raccoon
from I like what he [ __ ] said the
castor bonds are Arkansas ivory yeah
it's a long raccoon when I go go long
raccoon he's so amazing at coming up
with he's so unique I know
how's he doing I haven't talked to him
how's he doing with the Kovac thing
y'all quarantined up yes sir we had um
king of thing is [ __ ] I always have to
go home is that nothing to do because
they had a plant though plants got a
plan well that's good at least you can
stare at the plan dude plan yeah dude
how about Houston sold out already you
think there's a demand for people to get
me oh [ __ ] we're adding a couple shows
problem they don't add Sunday pop I can
be that Sunday people need this morning
have a show on Thursday bullet maybe a
show on Thursday calm down I know on
Thursday at 3:00 on Friday if you're
feeling froggy what oh you can't do
three ought to throw you you're older
I'll do three four and one day in Dublin
oh you oh yeah learn one day you can't
do through hey can I be honest with you
all [ __ ] aside
where's the love you're a big strong
athlete yes sir I have more endurance
than you right no Papa you get old down
oh you're back everything breaks down
we're doing fighter kids I said I was a
pop dude listen you mean your brother's
more show you and your brothers listen I
do more shows no no you don't say that
I'll beat you up last year no it doesn't
matter if you no no listen
well no over over a lifetime no no no no
no right now it's reaiiy I break you
down bubble me and your brother are a
couple of night hours right what cup of
vampires we stay up you that's different
that's there you got away well I don't
like people your Bey you [ __ ] go I'm
my back and then you break down I've
been little I shut it down like wow you
got my [ __ ] lower back I can't move
and then you have to waddle till night
all I see you like bars though you do to
9:30 you is not true you can't tire big
dogs get tired it's alright because
it'll fire like but Papa I'm gonna do
four [ __ ]
I'll do I'll do three shots there you go
see three 100% three four too much too
much for you not so much it gets like
worth a lot less divided by four you
feel sick yes by that fourth show you
feel sick no 100% I'll do three on
Friday and another one have we sold 700
taken in Spokane already yet you think
that and there's a lot there say mercy
and
foaming at the mouth and foaming it
there foaming at the dick I can't wait a
comedy
I can't wait we're gonna add Salt Lake I
think July 17 18 you how's that gonna be
the first thick boy bike club Festival
yeah it is Salt Lake City so we'll do
Salt Lake bring your stupid old ass how
many how many shows we do why don't we
do more than just two days I'm trying to
add the third gate and do three shows
every day okay Wow
what that can I just say one thing about
that that's high altitude Bubba high
altitude Oh old fun I don't want you I
don't want you alright get in the high
altitude I don't want you to really
adapt you know what you do have good
endurance yeah you always how did your
opponents so I wonder if that's from
living in Denver for real they say if
you're born of high altitude you do have
do you say that yeah it's not because
you do have very good cardio for a giant
we'll see who lasts longer on a bike if
you want or we can run you want to run
and see this back are you there only I
think I could beat you in all those the
problem is my feet my [ __ ] eyes I
have to be practice my god me too papa
you want to try it yeah see I don't want
to go endurance with me even at 53 you
just don't even in jiu-jitsu you know
what the joke was do you want to go
again Bryan I never got tired never go
just give Gynt at that no I didn't get
to keep content no I didn't get
something easy where I didn't get tapped
this is your hardest work that's not
true when I was training wow just
raining my salt you didn't see it I've
seen you trade multiple times when I
wasn't stopping to chip okay when I said
a jujitsu is my impression this is my
impression of Bryan he's taking a [ __ ]
this is my impression of Bryan and
jiu-jitsu gym fellas let's do it again
and they're like dude we're exhausted
tapping up come on more time yeah you
saw me wrestle with Jake Shields and all
you monsters no just regular people know
you've never seen me roll with regular
people and I got tricked let's not talk
about you just around Ruben okay we
don't put them on the we're both fans
and a Ruben
yeah I'm big that smart guy yeah is it
cool if I just saw you in the we can
stop and just say what's up no let's
keep going hey is it cool if I just
sucking them dick in the middle of the
show just so the fans have some yes so
it feels like lyrics fighter in the kid
and I go
hey should we call this episode the
Bryan Callen show yeah yeah pleasantly
surprised no I love him yeah
I'm speaking as the fan though you were
punching a bad egg we were fighting give
me a sock in the old nuts nice well the
ring usually they're wearing those steel
cups but I'll suck you right in your
stupid old ball right Dave Rubin well
the best underwear on the planet are a
little something called me under no my
god the world's most soft and
sustainable underwear period yep it
aimed to end your toxic relationship
with your tattered old undies and we all
have them you know the ones that have a
hole I've had a couple that have holes
and I keep wearing them oh my god
[ __ ] pee stains the front get rid I
throw them all away I throw them all
away the only you can build a pack with
me on these I'm telling you this right
now mate are the membership right every
month of Dhu nice and fresh undies
they're the best they truly are you
older pack you can even match these with
the other half musa made with soft sand
well fabric available in sizes extra
small Ryan yeah I'm for double ex Brenda
hey you guys get your 50% off your first
order free shipping and a hundred
percent satisfaction guaranteed go to me
on DS dot-com slash fighter that's me on
these dot-com slash fighters they are
the best underwear on the planet they
will last you forever
they're amazing oh you got 20% off 20%
off on it nutritions all their nutrition
all the nutrition do the same
semi-annual sale is happening right now
the MCT oil fat buddy out bar is great
for bringing on like pikes warriors or
bar I'm on your thick black active you
got that keto hot sauce got protein
powders you got coffee the [ __ ] yeah
coffee coffee with extra caffeinated
crystals in it they got it all twisted
off right now on it calm slash fighter
for tempers off the entire damn sight
but right now there's semi-annual sale
nutritions 20% off on it calm slash plan
the great Dave Rubin ladies and
gentlemen we've been we've been we know
all the same people we know all the same
people it's all mine believe it or not
it's a lot of spray in there right now a
lot of strikes nice yeah had it done
who's the young who's the young guys
young twink over there
that's my associate producer Michael
middle of lockdown I'm hiring I'm
expanding I'm weak all my oh you the
breath of fresh air my friend yeah you
are yeah well I've been watching Holly
to know that I'm doing anything that
interesting except that we live in a
very [ __ ] up time and a little common
sense apparently is it common sense
though because I feel like we need
people like you were well spoken to kind
of lay it out for people like me um yeah
that still makes a common sense you know
I mean most of the stuff I'm talking
about it's like I just want people to
live free I don't care what you do in
your private life I care what you do in
your private life I don't want any of
your money if you have more money than
me if I have more money than you you
can't have my money I just want people
to live free that really is it and yet
somehow that is thought of as Nazi stuff
yeah it we're just so upset when when
you say something and I yeah yeah
welcome to club yeah when you have a
yeah when you say something that makes
sense if people don't agree with they
get so upset oh you you just want more
people to die well no I don't want
anybody to die but people can die
regardless yeah I was thinking as I was
coming here because I don't get out that
often anymore how many people could I
kill could I touch a lot of mailboxes
lick exactly thing or yeah it's all it's
very bizarre okay you take the fight to
the college campuses which are yeah
which attention because I don't mean
interrupt you be before you go on with
your point have you seen what college
campuses are doing specially in the
southeast like this ec conference
because they're they're they're
controlling it better than anybody like
Vanderbilt and University of Tennessee
they're thriving in Tennessee so what
the sec is saying because in california
in the pac-10 they're not gonna they're
like well we can't play football that's
AC same yeah we can and so the NC
double-a goes well we want a blanket
rule we're not just
this conference can play in sec ghosts
no we're gonna play we're good to go why
would we wait on these dummies because
they don't have their [ __ ] together well
you see just in the last hour I saw a
video of the governor of Florida and
he's like hey if your state if you're a
basketball team football team if your
state's shutting you down we'll take
more professional franchises here it's
like I'm bigger to starting my own NBA
team there's only group is that right
all the pro teams yeah they're opening
up everything they're taking the pro
teams then the NBA all the big heads in
the NBA so player wise LeBron James
Steph Curry they go we want to play this
year we want to finish the season
because they were like well we don't
know if I gonna shut down well bronze
got together
LeBron needs the cash cuz I have a
friend that lives like a block away from
where he's building his new compound and
trust me that guys spending a pretty
penny like he needs to get back to work
yes probably doing it from the billions
from Nike alien dollars but yeah yeah
you do a lot of stand-up right oh yeah
and then you twelve not much right now
but wearing at all you're not doing um
so it's funny I did the 12 years of like
the struggling stand-up life in New York
handing out the tickets six nights a
week two hours a night and all that and
the road stuff and but that was all
before anyone knew me and you know it's
just like you show up at a club and
you're one out of ten guys and even if
you kill nobody remembers you and it was
sort of pre-youtube and all that stuff
and now it's weird because now because
in my show I can sell out a club so when
I was on tour with Jordan Peterson for
about a year and a half if we just had
an off night I would just do whatever
club was there to do about an hour I'd
like five jokes but I'm really it's not
I'm not even doing stand-up really I'm
just like running a circus like I get up
there I kind of talk about politics and
what's on my mind I get people involved
they give away [ __ ] like it's it's very
different but I love it like I don't
need I don't really want to be a comic
anymore so your show has become yeah
pretty much yeah which is nice [ __ ]
guests on there man
we work on but you don't know I love it
you just I just listened to it the guy
from Dirty Jobs micro that guy is
awesome how smart is he he's vocabulary
he is so impressive really oh yeah he
must right that was good that was a good
word really really good
I never thought of him that way uh my I
mean I watch this show religiously all
the time but then we hear him speak I go
my god well he's he's one of those guys
that's smart for the right reasons like
you could talk to academics all day I
interviewed these high level guys that I
loved I loved talking to him about that
guy I loved talking to those guys but
it's like it's like book-smart you know
and that's that's important obviously
but a guy like micro it's like his
smarts do come from something else cycle
like being down there with these guys
that work literally the worst dirty jobs
you can imagine and finding out like
what it is that they know about the
world you know like what if they figured
out how is it that you can like
literally be cleaning up [ __ ] all day
like animal [ __ ] or human [ __ ] and still
find purpose in the world still find
happiness all that stuff
he's been around those people and I
think that that kind of like that's what
I find when you when you do stand-up as
much as like I do or now you do yeah you
know one of the things that I know I
realized when I was always touring and
being around my audience with sometimes
younger or whatever but they were a lot
of blue collar middle class as I kind of
was like I actually don't know anymore
than they do yeah a lot of ways in fact
I'm very myopic in my existence I live
in LA and I'm an actor and I read and
stuff but in terms of living a practical
life you know that's it yeah that's
what's that's what's really interesting
well that's what's so funny it's like
I've only I was born in Brooklyn I grew
up in Long Island I went to SUNY
Binghamton I lived in Manhattan my whole
life and then I moved here seven years
ago so I have truly only lived in New
York in LA yet the things that I talk
about seems to resonate far more with
the people in the middle of the country
which is really weird and it's like no
joke right now I'm thinking about
leaving like I don't know what I'm doing
here and what do you want to go that's
what we were talking about taxes or I
don't know probably Texas maybe Florida
I think Texas the one I don't live in
Florida yeah I don't know why I don't
know that I want to live in Texas either
but like really I love this like the
idea that I would have to leave 85 and
sunny today we're in Santa Monica it's
perfect we can't go to the beach we've
got all of the worst types of people
running this state but our governor's
avenues has happened but isn't there is
it this is what leftism is isn't there a
part of you that wants to fight to stay
though there is a mom trust me that is
where I
the last 72 hours I have been at that
like internal thing constantly like do
you stay in fight even though there's
almost no evidence that you can turn
this thing around in this state or do
you just get out then they win I feel
like if we leave it like look look what
you on musk you know you want you want
to do what all right I'm gonna take my
facility I'm out here oh all right all
right you can open up like this I
thought they oppress that what happened
exactly
yeah they're letting him I guess they're
letting what did they do they're they're
letting the facility remain open or
something because they were gonna say
none of it can be opened just
non-essential goods but then they they
went back on that said well you can open
but there has to be a limit number
number of people right necessary
precaution the thing is that that Gill
girl um Eric Garcetti and Newsome and
all these people they that for a while
the California economy was doing really
well right before this yeah we're
crushed seems like a crazy gamble to
keep us shut down this long why are they
doing this so it depends how far down
the rabbit hole you want to go let's go
so look look there's the there's the
literal version of this which is okay
maybe they know something about Kobe
that they're not telling us you know so
maybe there that is but I don't know
about that it's like it's like we
crushed the curve nobody's sick the idea
that we really shouldn't be doing this
right now hospitals are empty the only
people that are that with minor
exceptions it's like if you're over 80
and already sick though those are the
people are younger obese have problems
or what younger and obese younger okay
so if we take all of that stuff it's
like that is not enough of a reason to
keep all of us who are in the prime of
life away from our friends from our
family like I don't know about you guys
but I was thinking the other day like I
want to hug my mom my man's in New York
but like this is crazy at this point
she's 70 she can't leave the house
basically so the rabbit hole though
would be if you want like that answer
its that they genuinely want to destroy
the economy so the Trump loses like I
mean is that I don't think it's that
crazy they threw everything at Trump
russia-ukraine this that the other thing
now there's all this Flynn stuff leaking
out that's gonna look really bad for
Obama and by
and it's like maybe they really remember
bill Mahr guy who I really like in a lot
of ways don't forget this is a guy who
two years ago was talking about how if
the economy crashed if that's what it
took to get rid of Trump then that would
be good like I think a lot of lefties
think like that like may think Hitler's
in charge as bananas as that is and what
would you do to take out Hitler if you
would ruin everything
point two percent unemployment did they
hell did they notice that we're a full
employment the I mean if they don't want
to get Trump out than any of that to
them and and for them they also don't
believe in numbers so it's like it
doesn't matter how many unemployed
people are because we'll just make up
money we'll just make up money to give
them and then you just keep these people
on the leftover government programs yeah
to fill in where private enterprise they
love that they love government programs
no matter how many times it keeps people
in perpetual poverty generation after
generation why can't I don't get why the
masses can't see the numbers and see
that it's gone to politics now more so
than they might have beating kovat and
being safe you know what I just got [ __ ]
for not wearing a mask in the coffee
yeah I mean talking about the masking
[ __ ] the truth is that people are just
complacent we live in the freest place
ever right now right like we have no
idea none of the three of us have any
clue what real oppression is what real
not having to fight Authority is there
are plenty of other people that are
American that do know that that came
here from Eastern Europe or that's
parent parents survived communism or
Nazi Germany or a zillion other things
we have no idea when it starts to come
and I get a lot of emails from people
all over the world that are like it's
starting to feel like that yeah it's
starting to feel like the government's
are just coming and that's the thing the
idea that I would leave Cali I freaking
love it here in my life is so good I
have a great home and home studio and
like I got everything I want it all came
together here and for the last three
weeks the thing that I can't get out of
my head is maybe you got to go yeah that
sucks I know it sucks but it's like but
to stay and fight things I think it
means this I don't know fighting it has
to with guys like you and Rogan and
Jordan Peterson the smarter Minds
translating it to the masses that's
quite listen I'm not a quitter I'm not a
quitter cuz I would have to do something
else right like I've been gotten a lot
of hate over the years so I'm not a
quitter but we should learn something
from Elon Musk who's a brilliant man who
was like no I'm not doing that man if
you do that I'm taking all these
employees and we're going to
listen I bet they bent the knee babe
Anthony I've been on Fox News basically
every day for the last three weeks
rallying against Newsome by name
rallying against Garcetti you know you
ever get any like sort of response from
them no but I've also bought by the way
I usually do it pretty respect him and
sometimes kind of jokey about them but
like I've invited them on my show I
would treat both of them exactly the
same way I've treated every other guest
which is with nothing but respect you
have a different job tell me your [ __ ]
tell me why I wanna do and that's it
give me my explanation I don't have one
with Garcetti when he's like yeah we're
locking up for three months that's it
you got it by the LA Times you're like
wait hold on why we beat the curve that
you told us May 15th I know but then you
don't give us any sort of explanation
and then they see the backlash and then
two minutes later after that gets
released he goes on CNN he's like no I'm
not saying it's gonna be the same
lockdown don't think businesses are
stilling stay open but it's just the
necessary steps like but no they don't
explain any he risks losing the next
election though I think these guys are
well he risks it he risks it if enough
people wake up but but so that's the
stay and fight question it's like have
these guys gone so bananas so off the
rails so drunk with power that even in
California enough people are just like
forget this I don't know that maybe
these are cynical enough to believe and
I I'm asking because I think I know that
like like an outfit like CNN yeah when
when they frame the amount of deaths
about what this one guy who's got a ball
see an outfit or alpha the way they the
way they they know an outfit in it they
will they will have a journalist on and
he'll say the equivalent of two towers
at 9:00 9/11 yeah Oh people is dying
every single day and people still don't
get it
and it's like is that what you're saying
and are you do you mind like having some
caveats around that how old are they are
we sure of that are they all being
tested there are all these questions
where you're like you're you're just you
are it's almost like they want this
lockdown to go on forever
they do well first off their ratings are
up in the midst of this because we're
all trapped at home so let
now the media is dead I mean that that's
an important thing too just like we have
to just say it and know it the
mainstream media is just absolute dead
CNN is the WWE it is I mean I think that
moment when you saw that moment when
Chris Cuomo walked out of his basement
yeah and they said well he's been he's
been in quarantine for three weeks and
here a guy and he had the shivers and he
chipped a tooth because he had kovat and
but and it's like he comes up and he's
sweating and then he's here now to go
was cuz he was working out downstairs
while he had Cova the whole things it's
all fixed I mean just a week before he
had said it was in quarantine for three
weeks it turns out a week before he got
into a fight with a biker outside her
house in the Hamptons and there's but
it's like it's all made-up nonsense we
are watching WWE skits in front of us
and pretending it's real why don't
people get it no they saw on I'm on a
book tour right now I have done every
freaking podcast you can think of I've
been on every Fox show repeatedly I
would go on every single CNN show here
I'm saying it again I have not gotten
one invite not one end right from MSNBC
they're just afraid they just they just
my only caveat though would be I would I
would only do it live because I don't
trust them on the editorial side but Fox
I go on live they don't tell me to say
anything I was supposed to be on Perino
right before I got here but then the
splint story drops so they canceled me
they are so polarized aren't we in this
country this them it's just so [ __ ]
well I think most of us are like this
most people were the fortunate ones
don't you know we're fortunate in that
we're not like completely partisan crazy
people wandering around thinking that
Nazis are hunting us down or that half
the country is evil or something like
that most people aren't you meet most
people it's like most people are willing
to admit they don't know everything most
people are willing to admit that you
know they want to figure out a way to
live with other people but the media has
just they have just failed us just cuz
that thing says CNN and you remember
that for the twenty years ago doesn't
mean anybody like even with foul Chi
it's like take him into consideration
when he came out and goes you know he's
been on the record yeah if this is
nothing it's not a big deal fast word
month later this the worst thing ever
where mass Pryor that don't wear masks
none of it makes a that he's wrong it's
okay to say that you're wrong he their
projections were so far off by the way
somebody's also might have to do with
pouchy being very old and a risk
he's just protecting himself well I mean
there's an emotion sky you know yeah
he's up very you don't get in that
business stop being a very cautious
person well they give those that scale
of what was it 200 million a die yeah
and then you know $60,000 night well you
know they're just so far off I'm sure
somebody said 200 million though I'm a
gavin newsom said we had we're at risk
of having 87 or 90 95 percent of the
California population being infected by
Kovac but but the thing is but then they
say that sorry
no no they're gonna say well the only
reason that didn't happen went in the
quarantine course okay but then we
caught but yeah how about Sweden mouth
these other states but how about in
quarantine what in even the governor of
New York came out and said that what
they've realized is by locking down the
family it's spreading like crazy because
they're all stuck together so that being
locked down the quarantine doesn't make
sense
I think you can look at it this way
let's say we were truly like in a
dystopian future right now and we knew
for sure that 10% of Americans were
gonna die no one's saying this is true
so I'm giving you like a ridiculously
over-the-top scenario let's say really
they were like we know it right now
10 percent of Americans are gonna die
that's a crazy number that means every
one of every one of us would know
multiple people who died all that stuff
at some point even knowing that we'd
still have to start living again yeah
that's the thing I think they've tricked
us into thinking you know you keep
seeing this where they'll be like we
can't end this until the until there's a
vaccine there's no vaccine for the
common cold no I know life is about risk
right life is about risk you go out you
get punch you get into fight you get hit
by a car you mean the Lydia you could
have a freaking you know Brown Deer a
with as far as deaths cuz you look at
deaths over the board from heart attacks
to the flu the common flu to all these
other things cholesterol obesity we're
fine with those but then you like you
the numbers of this which are much
smaller and we're not like over it's not
that deadly how about that
it's not that deadly if you're older
look if you're older it'll be if you're
older it is and it is more deadly than
the flu from what I understand but but
either way the point is we're gonna have
they're gonna push us to a place where
good people are just gonna be like
forget this I'm gonna just go ahead and
live my life
the idea that right now that I can't
invite friends
who are young and healthy over for
dinner I mean I guess we could do it on
the DL I feel like I've been yeah yep
look my hair is a little shorter than it
was the stranger came into my house and
clip my hair told me how much he hated
truck the whole time and then left
hey Trump and still be against this
shutdown no a blanket shutdown of course
I don't have to be a Trump supporter and
be for common sense right but this idea
that the anti Trump people they always
have to express it no matter what it's
like dude you have no idea what I think
about anything he didn't know who I am
doesn't even matter but like these
people that have to walk in and express
all of can you cut my hair yeah you got
a scissor right now you got to go on
your ante Trump never liked vegans no
nose but Michael a producer here he got
a hair I don't want to say his hair's a
little shorter than it was the other day
too from another guy and he has a Trump
bobblehead in his apartment and the guy
came in and start ranting about Trump
too it's like these people could do your
job yeah do your job unless your job is
to hate Trump which then you get a job
at CNN yeah it really is true man how is
it opening for Jordan Peterson what kind
of crowd is that did you and you're not
you're not doing you're not doing stay
are you doing open it with stand-up or
it's mostly crowd work and I like drop
some funny references about him and he
sounds like Kermit the Frog and he talks
about lobsters a lot like a lot of like
insider Jordans yeah but it was
incredible I mean we did a year and a
half together a hundred and twenty shows
something like 20 countries I went to
all these places not only in America but
all over the world that I had never been
to Finland Sweden you know I've never
been to Ireland before the crowds when
he goes to Finland well the Sweden shows
were incredible because Sweden has a
major political correctness problem
because yeah they're they really view
conformity as good in Sweden so it's
always very funny when all the AOC is
and Bernie they're like we should be
more like Sweden it's like well actually
what you're saying is we should be like
this absurdly tiny homogeneous country
that now in the last couple years
they've led an immigrant's and now they
have all sorts of problems so they don't
even know what they're talking about but
Sweden the show sold out literally in a
minute so we added a second one so we
left Sweden came I think we went to
Finland and came back the shows mostly
were in theaters that were like probably
two to six thousand I
six was the biggest every single show
was sold out I think maybe except for
one we I think the show in Dallas they
put us in like they put us in the Toyota
Center have you ever been there it's
like it's not it's not a theater it's
basically like a giant Convention Center
so you can't sell it out because again
just following he changed people's lives
yeah I saw things that you cannot
imagine I'm talking people off drugs
people it will every addiction name an
addiction he solved people's addictions
people I'll give you one we we finished
the show in Dublin and you know when you
walk out the artists entrance because
you know he doesn't want to get mobbed
right out in front and he's had a day I
mean we got that we got to town that
morning signing all the autographs all
the meet and greets taking all the
pictures the press hits an hour and a
half lecturer that was different every
night he's beat it's like 1:00 a.m. we
walk out the side and we see these two
guys in the alleyway and ones like about
60 the other ones maybe 25 or so and
they're both crying and they're hugging
they kind of run up to us and it turns
out that it's a father and son who had
had a falling out five years before had
not seen each other in five years they
both bought the book oh then both ended
up at the show saw each other come on
and made amends that night tell us the
story now Jordan starts crying his wife
with it was with us she starts crying
the tour manager John starts crying I
start crying I mean it was like like you
like you can't make something more real
you can and when they make the movie
about Jordan and when they remake that
scene it will not be as powerful as it
was it was like and I saw a lot on that
so I can't say anything that's not
public I spoke to him last week and I
saw him a few months ago he's getting
better
um he you know they try to frame it like
he's like it was like a drug addict and
all this stuff he was very open about it
his wife in the midst of his success in
the midst of like this unprecedented
worldwide like crazy success his wife
was diagnosed with terminal cancer I was
out to lunch with him you know in think
we were in Des Moines when he got the
call and and we continued he continued
and he was very open about being on a
very small amount of klonopin which is
an anti-anxiety drug and then as things
got worse with her and she wasn't able
to tour with us he upped the amount and
he regrets it and he did and and then
what
happens with some of these anti-anxiety
ziz it actually has they call it a
rubberband reaction or something where
you actually end up instead of being you
know you the idea is that if you take
more oh you're gonna have less anxiety
but eventually it just actually does the
complete reverse but he's getting better
he's getting better he's his books
coming out I think and they're just
thoughts on ops he's not here but what's
his thoughts on kovaydin office i've
only the only thing i can say is that
what jordan i think wants to fight in
this world more than anything else is
authoritarian government he that is his
main thing that he wants to stop he
wants people to be free he wants exactly
what i said at the beginning it's
amazing how authoritarian yeah these
quote-unquote liberal governments are
yeah it's amazing how authoritarian
someone like Gavin Newsom and and Eric
Garcetti are it's actually astonishing
snitch on your nape snitch I need it how
much could you make today yeah I saw my
guy walking his dog pocketed 50 bucks
yeah that's right and it's it's just
astonished our friend ash yet snitch
time I know what for doing what for
having for having a product guest we're
having a podcast a man our friend who
for let my son play in his gym oh that's
right there's three other letting
children jump on a trampoline giant
warehouse right because I was gonna say
podcasts are exempt somehow this is
exactly go I would never stop doing it
yeah I would do this underground and
just be like [ __ ] off I'm just I'm so up
for the record I like we were talking
about I'm so against this shutdown well
it's like the things that make the upset
me and I feel like I I want to fight but
I don't know even where to start but I
sent chin this video there's this cop in
Washington he's a former Army Ranger
he's a jujitsu gym owner father of three
wife and he's on the police force there
have you seen this video it's gone
pretty bad yeah I think his name's Greg
Anderson reg Anderson the og gr engine
33 is his so he gets on that he's in his
patrol car and he goes man I feel like I
have to say something about this he was
I'm a police officer in Washington and
goes and a lot of my colleagues are
arresting people for basically you know
it's against the Constitution what we're
doing he goes some of these people are
but they're small business whether it's
a nail salon in their house of
barbar so got that he goes and I have
colleagues going undercover to catch
these and he put think were criminals
she's going on Curt and arrest them take
him from their family he goes I'm not
gonna do that
it's against the Constitution we're not
allowed to do that and goes and the
problem is is you're gonna wake up a
sleeping giant the American public hears
once they realize that we don't have the
power to do this there's gonna be
problems there's gonna be bloodshed he
said I don't want that bloodshed so and
then so he does that video right gets
whatever a million something views and
he wasn't my sergeant also believes the
same way that I do so I'm fortunate and
I guess it the sergeant goes alright
you've got four hundred seven thousand
views you need to take this down it's
not not taking down stake your point why
I take down that you're cool you're
fired so he lose his job he's called him
and said the administration said look
this is this is gonna get to the next
level you got to take it down and accept
a letter of reprimand and he's like well
I can't do that I'm willing to die in
this he'll this is what I believe is
right and I don't believe that there's
anything that's more sacred than the
Constitution in the United States not
higher up authorities not elected
officials if they are an affront to the
Constitution if they are if they are
butting against that that that's when
that's what you define yourself and what
you willing to fight for well he is a
man for your freedom yeah this is a
[ __ ] who fights for what he
believes in he's a very rare dude wait
so what's his situation right now he got
fired didn't have a job they let him go
Michael we gotta hunt this guy down I
got this yeah he's brought him up afraid
of leave and then about to be fired he's
fired now but he said it's about to be
fun I'm pretty sure he's fired now and
he started a GoFundMe office he has
three little children his protect here's
a gym his jiu-jitsu blackbelt he's one
he's one of us it'd be even better yeah
well look that's so then that's the stay
at fight part that I can get on board
with it's like if we can cause a mass
awakening it's like this is just a man
he's just a man that that woman in
Dallas who opened up her salon and did
everything that anyone would do you know
I mean you're gonna wear a mask you saw
the video probably she goes around
saying this is you're gonna be so you'll
be clean here was socially distance my
workers want to put food on their kids
tables right and that judged that smug
awful judge can you imagine
get somebody who's telling you that they
want to make sure their kids and say a
government bureaucrat that's all you are
and saying to them you have to apologize
Oh crazy as if as if that's what you're
in the government for is is as if that's
what the judiciary tolik [ __ ] but
yeah nothing at yeah yeah but there's
very sick there's been movements where I
think if you want to stay in fight you
can see certain things I keep going back
to you on Moscow's he has incredible
power with the Tesla plant in Northern
California you look at this gentleman
who's the police officer he lost his job
you know there's a there's a ton of
things or in Orange County
when Newsom came out we're shun down the
beaches in orange and then the chef came
out went I want every citizen to know in
Orange County we're not gonna obey by
that we're not gonna arrest people for
going the beach that's not happening is
okay well not Orange County yeah well
you know one of the things is there's a
weird thing in California particularly
that if you fail in government you
always move up so Gavin Newsome
destroyed San Francisco destroy what
when's the last time you guys were in
Sandra's it's a great point destroy
business there I know a cop there it is
it's a literal [ __ ] and I'm using
the word literally correctly they have
an app that tells you where human [ __ ]
is on the street I mean actually tells
you where human [ __ ] is that's not you I
was there as right as such a riot jumper
no I know who does that up like god
dammit can fly up Fremont Street man so
it took a big [ __ ] over there take a
look at the Tenderloin I should love
Sarah this looks like they love sale of
weed they love dogs I should love it
there and it's like the not only that
but I was there right as the lockdowns
are starting I was I was trying to raise
some money for something for this tech
company I'm doing and and it was just
getting weird but the amount of people
that I saw shooting up homeless people
everywhere homeless encampments video I
saw a man I was talking to my front our
can happen with you talking it was down
to Pier the man 60 years old came
walking with a briefcase and well he's
naked right he did have a copy of
conquering yo not a [ __ ] reading it was
around his balls and his [ __ ] it was
like a super country I was walking like
nothing was it was just what you do it's
like we're like we were bothering him
roll in San Francisco's you can walk
around completely make it with with a
[ __ ] or whatever I don't know what that
is what yeah you tie off at the base
either way it's important but if you if
you are in any way hard well not you
either get arrested now you gotta put
something you can walk around with a
flaccid penis yeah no no I know it's
hard really chatty yeah have you seen
Twitter they're leaving Silicon Valley
they're out I saw that they're now a
billion dollar company see you guys can
stay at home and work if you want but
we're at it did you see this thing
somebody posted online a picture of what
you can get for two million bucks and I
think Menlo Park which is like you know
the heart of Silicon Valley kind of
stuff San Francisco versus what you get
for 2 million bucks in like you know
rural Virginia or something and it's
like you can literally get a one-bedroom
one-bathroom house that you would have
to knock down to have you know a
sixteenth of an acre or you can
literally have a fight beyond a farm you
could have been a strong pounds yeah
stay move everyone there start your own
country yeah so people but again these
are because progressive policies build
the government to the point where
everything ultimately collapses and so
that's what he did to San Francisco and
now he's running the state so the stay
and fight thing is like yeah maybe we
should do it maybe we should do it I'm
not really cases where it works yeah I
get elected how the [ __ ] did California
he's got he's got good hair and nice
teeth
yeah that's why speaking he's got a nice
tan that sucks
that's it he's just a stuff so so so
what do you think happens with this
August first kind of lockdown so is this
official now I've been in the midst of
this press tour so I'm missing a little
bit of Newsies this three-month thing
now history just came out and said yeah
it's gonna be we'll go through the
stages but but it's not gonna be a total
lockdown but we're not gonna be sitting
down to restaurants anytime soon you
know some eateries might open under very
strict guidelines it just you'll see
people put up with like when you drove
here today but you know I drive a
distance
the traffic's building up oh yeah I'm
bored just like now dude alright we've
had enough well I do think there's a lot
of desert do we have a half man I have I
have a friend sun's out it's booming I
think time there comes a time where it
might be worth actually
mounting a resistance getting out in the
street or whatever it is I mean or just
or how about this how about nonviolent
protesters they've done that my friend
but you know what they're gonna call you
for doing that kind of stuff you've got
your god-given right no they're gonna
call you a Nazi I mean that's what they
did with the people in Michigan they got
out there they started defending their
rights right and it doesn't mean that
every single one of those people did it
right and you can talk about well
alright we're gonna produce we got out
Master all that stuff but what did what
did the media do there but a bunch of
Nazis a bunch of racists and I mean it's
exactly what they did to the Tea Party
you know that's exactly it don't you
think that's a little bit what's going
on to with with governors and elected
officials where I think someone want to
open up but they're scared of the
backlash because you see the like the
Arizona governor the governor in Atlanta
and know how to open up and the Florida
governor they get so much [ __ ] man and
once again you're not he's getting you
guys are killing people so I think a lot
of these governors like we don't want to
deal with that negativity from the media
so we're gonna stay lockdown I think the
bigger issue is that there are all
hypocrites of the highest order that
Batwoman Whitmer the governor in
Michigan she's out there she's out there
talking about you can't plant seeds and
you can't do landscaping and you're in
your own yard now think about the like
level of legit insanity first off seeds
I'm not much of a farmer although I am
growing some stuff now because of this
but seeds usually start in your house
you don't even start them outside so
that's number one number two what right
does the governor have to say you can't
plant things on your own property and by
the way that woman's face is so filled
with Botox I am pretty sure pretty hot I
am pretty that is a photogra street
right there I am pretty sure she's still
getting Botox no and that's the story
that I want that I want somebody to
break break that story that this woman
is getting Botox in the middle of this
thing because I have no I hope and you
have to go about it I want to have it
all wrinkled on her phone are you more
with her then have makeup sex yeah damn
you she's ahead on her that is a botoxed
face yeah now that's just fine if you
want a Botox but I know for sure if she
goes into a lockdown the second she
needs Botox she's getting that boat I'm
Nancy [ __ ] Nancy frickin Pelosi she's
my fridge right now I'm sure like you
you guys I got I got basically chicken
and and beef in there that's it that's
what
i shredded I I went to uh to Whole Foods
and I was like hey you know maybe I'll
get some ice cream and then I was like
no I can't get ice cream because I gotta
fill this with stuff to eat actually in
case all hell breaks loose Nancy
Pelosi's got those huge fridge they're
all filled with super expensive ice
cream it's like they are the worst type
of people on the planet the worst type
of hypocrites they want to control us
while they live on the till well what
about this I don't have to deal with the
consequence what about this absentee
ballot did you see my tweet the other
day now so I'm not up chin I got nest
pull up my tweet from like two or three
days ago
I have nest in front of my house and
someone walked up to my mailbox and this
has happened a couple times it's
probably about a day or so ago you'll
see a picture of a guy in a mask of
course he's wearing a mask a guy just
walked up to my mailbox I saw him take
the mail out I have the whole video of
it I only put a picture it's coming
about the title of your book nice book
Thanks yeah I did a bunch of Star Wars
memes for a lot of Star Wars talked
about to talk about lockdown there it is
so this guy you can click the picture I
have the whole video he's also got a gun
on his shirt that's nice
he just walks up to my door he grabs the
mail he stuffs it in his underwear and
walks away my neighbor has the video too
and the neighbor across the street has
the video too so to answer your question
do I think that mailing ballots is the
right way to do it right now yeah if you
want to figure out a way to screw over
the most amount of people and you trust
these I tried to send the do you know
comic named Jimmy door by any chance you
know Jimmy yeah so I'm sending him a
copy of my book and he lives it I don't
he lives in LA proper I don't to say
what part but I literally mailed it 10
days ago I checked you USPS tracking
yesterday it's still n route like are
these the people you want to charge you
your ballots and these guys it's like
who are these people that you know maybe
he's just some crazy drug addict or god
knows what
or Stoli remote it's like are people
just gonna run around stealing ballots
so nobody can vote I mean the idea that
that right now in the midst of the
freaking monumental chaos that we're in
we're gonna also change how we vote that
seems like a good idea don't you are you
very pessimistic I always say I'm a
world-weary optimist because I'm a
realist first more than anything else
but I would say I'm Optima
stick because I don't know how the hell
I could do what we do otherwise how
could you talk for a living well I just
face it we're all like for me it just
seems like so against common sense and
so obvious that there's something going
on I'm not a conspiracy guy yeah yeah
I'm definitely not I just don't think
people are this a little more now I mean
I'm I'm just cynical enough to believe
that someone like Gavin Newsom and
Garcetti and Pelosi maybe they do want
to tank the economy or maybe they just
was their last hope to you trumpet is it
maybe that well there but that's not
that big of a conspiracy theory like you
we see out like like with Biden when
that represent came out go yeah we know
he's under investigation for rape and
that stuff but even with that I'd rather
have a rapist there than Trump like but
wait yeah right or was last year it was
believe all women now it's believed all
women except that women yes or the
believe all women except that woman it's
like everything that they have put on us
in the last couple years would leave you
to be a conspiracy theorist now they ran
with Russia for a year nobody gotten
punished for that Matt I was still on
air they ran with Ukraine for a year
they told us Brett Kavanaugh is her
rapist but now Biden is innocent
literally the same exact people right
the same exact people so it's like in a
weird way we're all conspiracy theorists
right now because there's so few people
making sense so maybe that gets us back
where they started here like thing is I
wonder if there's a way rather than try
to win these arguments I wonder if
there's a way to change people's minds
and I don't think that a lot of the
people on the Left are bad people I just
think in my opinion many times in many
positions they might be very just just
mistaken they know like we all have our
biases they usually are probably very
compassionate people and stuff there's
got to be a way I like her this is how I
think about it is like Rogan and I were
talking about this instead of being
attached to your ideas let's put the
ideas all out on a table and let them
battle it out without taking it
personally it's just an ideas you might
have the wrong ideas in your head I've
been doing it for five years I mean
that's that's literally the exact point
of my fools yeah how does it go
sometimes well sometimes terrible yeah
look the bulk of the students are good
and they want to hear you and and all
that kinda stuff although everything
being equal I'm only invited by
conservatives and libertarians
oh yeah I never I got one invite that
was going to be a co invite between the
Democrats and the Republicans House
Democrats and Republicans and then then
the Democrats pulled out at the last
second so I never get invited by
anything other than then say
right-leaning things but the thing is
mama because I would love to talk to
them yeah you know I swear to you every
single college gig I've ever done when I
do QA I say if you disagree with me you
come up first
every single one yeah and usually
usually you can get them to have some
level of a conversation but if they come
and they're ready to just kill you
there's there's a video that I have on
YouTube
it's got like three million views that
when I went to University of Utah and it
is what these kids ran up to start
trencher kids run chanting screaming
pounding noisemakers screaming I'm a
Nazi there's a woman in the video love
this there's a woman in the back I think
you could just search Dave Rubin New
Hampshire because it's from a couple
it's from like two years ago there's a
woman in the back screaming that I hate
trans people I'm and I'm a Nazi right so
I've been going on about I watch Finnish
yeah to try not you up for Holocaust
survivors I mean all this [ __ ] so did
you don't want you in the face no so I
did not I did not but I will tell you
what you'll appreciate this at the
comedy level so at one point so I deal
with them for for two hours totally
respectfully I'm not attacking anybody
but then at one point you know you know
like from stand-up like then you have to
start doing some other tricks when it's
like not quite working so at one point I
just looked at these two kids they're
mindlessly chanting at me they're like
literally as far as we are and they
won't look me in the eye that's the
other thing
because they don't want even humanize
you so they're looking away and I kept
saying those beaches hey hey guys you
know look me in the eye let's whatever
you want to whatever you think I believe
let me let me explain it but they won't
do it and now they keep chanting so
finally I go guys could you just shut
them and that's how I said it and I said
it a couple times like totally sarcastic
right then the write-up in the school
paper Dave Rubin loses his cool and
tells audience to shut the [ __ ] up and
it's like no that is the reverse of what
happened is this it yeah oh and what you
really love about this is the reason I'm
looking up is because they move the
event they said they couldn't secure the
room on campus because of the protesters
so they moved a 300 person event to a
six thousand seat hockey room so
I'm standing with five look at that I
got 5500 empty seats behind me oh these
were the two those were the two that
were they refused to look at me
and I'm going you know you know just
talk to me what do you guys at I'm on
from their standpoint like what what are
they trying what were they mad at well I
think they don't know what they're don't
know this woman
so this woman's yelling at me that I
hate trans people I'm a Nazi I go up I'm
like oh and then she says she's trans so
I said well look I want you to live with
the same exact decency and under the
same laws and I hope you have someone
that loves you and all I said everything
that I truly believe and she's still
screaming I'm a Nazi I didn't find this
out till about three weeks later it
turned out she was a gender studies
professor at the University so she they
have a professor at the University I
don't know he's on but no not her not
the working those no no these were the
two that were chanting that I kept
saying look at me in the eye and just
tell me what look like let's drink and
turn it up yeah is there a minimum guy
that's gonna or just please listen guys
guys guys look at me black lives matter
I mean you can at least look at me there
you go all right look you sure Michael
do you think anyone's here for you do
you think anyone's here for you I agree
black lives matter
I agree black lives matter do not play
the quiet game we'll try it that way
guys okay what a disaster
what a [ __ ] this is what you have to
deal with listen you got the script down
I'm an impress to with the repetition
the fans are laughing oh yeah that's
good I see some black people because are
they saying to be quiet
are they assuming you think black lives
don't matter what was their agenda it
doesn't see this is the thing that
people don't understand about it why are
you enjoying this this woke thing like
good people like what you're asking me
is what a sane person would ask right
like what a thinking person would ask
like what is going on in their minds
this woke thing it truly is a mind virus
so right now we're fighting Corona
Corona is a virus what is a virus a
virus is easy to catch right that's why
everyone's nervous about my about Corona
and then what's the other thing about a
virus it's hard to get rid of and that's
what this is all of these ideas that
everyone's racist
everyone's homophobic I am oppressed
even though I'm walking around with an
iPhone and I can do whatever I want
these these are very easy ideas to catch
because it just it it makes you feel
morally good you know and it's like if
you live in the United States of America
in 2020 you are them that's pretty much
school you're in a college like that
bear bear when they're literally you can
see parts of this where they're going we
could be shot when we walk out of here
oh really are they just shooting people
down at the University of New Hampshire
maybe that was the transfers in there
possibly or this is them oh this girl
this hurls friends - no no no no she's a
real piece of work though she she told
me that my that I told her something
about that I had relatives who survived
the Holocaust and I lost family members
nagas she said they'd be rolling over in
their graves they'd be rolling over in
their graves if what was it that you
were saying that was that that they had
a problem with nothing literally more
I'm not if that's the thing it's nothing
what do I want I'm telling these kids I
want you to live free I don't want
people to be racist all I'm saying is I
want people to be treated equal under
the law but they've they've created some
alternative situation in their head
where they need that oppression anybody
stand up for you today buddy
oh yeah well the funny thing is that so
there's about 400 kids there the
original event was supposed to be three
oh there's there's no the one in the
back the red one I feel pretty sure it's
her sir yeah okay oh she got mad yeah
she's the gender stuff have your hands
full she watched on the stereo but wait
this is you'll find this interesting so
I didn't want to put this video up I
actually asked turning point right
before I said let's not video this
because I know all hell's gonna break
loose and I don't want to add fuel to
the fire and then right before it
started I was like you know what just
just tape it just in case so then what
happened was these kids that are
videotaping the whole thing they
selectively edited to make it seem like
I'm saying racist things they literally
cut words like a lot or didn't or out
and then and then what happens is these
loser youtubers left the youtubers that
hate me and spend all day putting videos
up about me they start airing these
clips Dave Reubens racist devar butts
are all off all of that so then I was
like all right this is the game you
morons want to play then here's the
whole video so I didn't even want to put
this up but you know and it's like dad
why do this why do it
a lot of people there do appreciate why
I do it cuz a lot of people do
appreciate it and believe it or not like
this one was sort of painful because I
did feel a sense of physical threat like
there are moments where it was really
getting crazy as genderless but but I do
believe you can change these kids minds
and if you don't do it I mean she's
literally calling me a Nazi right there
and I'm lying to her I'm referring to
her as her with her pronouns and you
know you're trying to bet that's a man
so she wasn't miked up that is a
professor at a university that's the
professor I'm only gay after ten it's
all right so that's pretty good so what
if I said that is that is so offensive
to you I am a hundred percent for you to
have the same exactly this what I just
said else in this country as I am a
hundred percent for you to have every
every law and legal protection that
anyone else in this country has so what
is it that you don't want me to say that
I have said here well I was about to get
to that until you started screaming yeah
all right well you know what here's the
thing I hope they pay you well this
speech so did you catch what she said
there what she said is I I'm okay with
people being misgendered now I am okay
with that I don't want the government
telling you that you can't refute that
you can to compel your speech meaning
that if trans person walks by me on the
street and I say hi ma'am and it turns
out to be a guy I don't want to be
jailed or fined I'm not running around
trying to offend people but by the way
comedian you're allowed to offend people
this is a crazy person first there's or
it's already something going on yeah
yeah I mean in a lot of ways she
controls her biology I'm not talking
about getting trained I don't know
enough about the trans mindset I think
some people feel like they're women and
men we get show up to his thing and then
do this and say to get the [ __ ] out
she's not [ __ ] out an argument well
also his insults it's also it's also I'm
a hundred percent sure against whatever
code she's just subscribe to as a member
of the faculty at the university as a
Elte member you can't go to a public
event at the school and shout speakers
down but of course there's and I'm not
trying to pile on her but like but even
right now I'm saying her I'm not I'm not
being a dick about it you know I mean
yeah what kid in the rogue shirt looks
like he's had enough he was definitely
happened I think a lot of times with
kids when you have crazies like this
that's a crazy yeah and you have these
insane extreme policies they end up
getting made fun of oh yeah whole gender
movement now has kind of lost its steam
I know it's made its way into boardrooms
and stuff like that but for the most
part people kind of we all gonna roll
our eyes like especially we're like
alright dude what is that is that
butterfly a male or a female and my
friend's son goes dad you just called
that butterfly a he how do you know it's
a he's joking around sixteen so so we're
all some of the stuff is impossible to
keep up with right so in level of light
a lot of people are bored to don't stand
for money they lock on to these
ridiculous ideas cuz it gives them a
sense of purpose well that's what it is
they don't I mean this is why Jordan
Peterson got the amount of hate that he
got what he was doling out to people was
purpose like his message is actually you
if you look at all 12 rules it's not one
of those rules is something that you
don't know is the right way to live your
life stand up straight with your
shoulders back meaning present something
to the world that is positive because
that will start the way clean your room
what are you saying is clean your room
so that were you telling kids a lot of
clean their room bingo because everyone
you know like think about the times in
your life when your room was a freakin
disaster
like think about college smoking a lot
of pot watching a lot of porn like my
room is a freaking nightmare yeah it
tells you that your life is out of
control now my room is very clean my
house is very clean it's not that you
have to be a clean freak but the idea
that puts some order into your life all
of these 12 rules are things like that
but they hate them they hate them they
hate him for that because their whole
ideology is not meant to fix themselves
it's to say the world is ahead and
that's why they're not happy yes and
there's nothing you can do about it and
that is that's anti human to be human is
to just go all right some of us are born
rich some of us are born poor some of us
are born strong some of us are born weak
I mean a bajillion other things but you
got to figure it out these ideas these
ideas are our bad ideas in general I
heard
New York Times reporter saying the
President as usual to criticize
Americans people have to feel
comfortable going back to work and they
don't the president's job is to make you
I was like the president's job is to
make us feel cup yeah I don't look to
the president make me feel comfortable
that was what he was like yeah yeah you
guys better feel what are you talking
about it's amazing to me the they'll
come up with a there are more kids now
at home with a with alcoholic fathers
that are abusing them right and what
happens what does the media say there
needs to be government programs to
counteract this problem but I think a
lot of people get back to the the thing
where these kids are lost don't have an
agenda and then they lump onto this
whatever is the woke culture but also
even with this coveted in this
quarantine it gives these negative
people something to grab on to and so
they get other negative people yeah we
should stay lockdown people are gonna
die it's like dude what are you doing
well that so yeah I think you're really
on to some of that because they've gone
from Oh Russia took over the election
but that didn't really affect us as
humans and now it's you are going to die
if you walk outside so it's like what's
the next version of it and the part of
me that wants to go you know what [ __ ]
it I'm out of here
terms of California is the part that
where it's like alright we give them
three more months and then literally the
day before you know now it's November 6
there it's the day before the election
they're like we're open up tomorrow now
they're like got saw a bump six more
months that I just don't have faith that
these people are I don't believe they
are good people and by good I don't I
don't mean they're inherently evil cuz I
I think what you said before his right
eye the road to hell is paved with good
intentions I don't know the Gavin Newsom
is sitting in his castle the guy's worth
a couple million bucks that if not him
and Pelosi related somehow and there's
definitely yeah there's he's involve
plump Jack wines yeah he's got a lot of
money right right but I assure you it's
not from the wines I think that he's
making his real money he's definitely
worth 20 million 20 million yeah I don't
begrudge him that by the way I wish I
had 20 million bucks that would be great
I'm jealous of his hair he's a
good-looking dude I'll you mutt but like
the idea is do you think that that guy
in an eric garcetti here in in LA do you
think these people are the people that
are going to free you
are they gonna free you or they think
I'm another agenda yeah do they have
their own agenda what's your book about
this yeah yeah really yeah I mean it's
about the the irony of the book is I
finished it in July so I didn't know
that any of this [ __ ] was happening
obviously but the ideas that I talk
about in the book it's it's literally
this I talk about states rights let the
states be free think about it the other
way if we didn't have states rights
imagine that would just leave one guy
basically the president who half the
country thinks is Hitler to be in charge
of the whole operation the fact that
Texas can do what Texas wants that
Florida can do what Florida wants and by
the way maybe they'll make some mistakes
along the way but the fact that you are
allowed to move within your country and
go to a place that is more in line with
what you believe is so freaking
beautiful and our founders they figured
that out that's what the Federalist
Papers are they figured out holy cow we
gotta give people as much mobility as
much movement and control over their
lives and yet here we are in California
that has what like the fourth biggest
economy in the world or something and
it's a massive geographic thing and it's
like where can I go in California I'm
gonna go to Sonoma that would be nice so
like I got that I got the same problems
there with a you know Sonoma has
problems than that that the lockdown
till August 1st is LA County so I think
if you're in venture and some of these
other county at Orange County they're
gonna go back to business cyla County
what was the reason there's no there's
no reason they don't they they don't a
lot because they say something that that
it's like the Word of God that they have
did you see the video when the when the
the day that the beaches shut down the
deputy mayor did that video in the
helicopter and he shows the empty
beaches and the way he tweeted it it
basically was like he was bragging like
like you're supposed to show LA Beach is
packed with people for that commercial
remember then California come to
California commercial that's what you're
supposed to do instead he's showing this
thing as if see how great we are look
what we've done we've shut down the
beaches and it's like and of course I
invited him on the show I do all that
stuff and they won't know or do or
they're scared to talk about it
because they don't want an argument they
don't have an app they can do they can
do three minutes sound bites on CNN
where the question is asked they can
answer it any which way and they go to
commercial that's it that's why the
podcast thing and Rogan and all of these
things this it's like this is what
they fear this is what they fear more
than is you've got to defend your
argument you know how to make a credible
argument and and I'm just I still am so
blown away by the fact that they are
gambling on the fact that people will be
okay with this right you're destroying
it's a big gamble and yeah yeah it's
against you know the Constitution it's
just it's it to me it's just when it
when is especially kalak they don't
think the Constitution is good-looking
in there like I can never say I'm a
Republican because I'm pro-choice yeah
and I'm just not religious enough to you
know I just I'm very pro-choice yeah and
so but I like a lot of what Republicans
stand for otherwise like gun rights
right so you want a small government and
but I I'm also socially liberal as [ __ ]
like I don't think the state should be
involved in the marriage business if you
I believe in gay marriage you're a
batterer I'm a libertarian I'm not as
big a libertarians I do think there's
room for government I think that I don't
want to be careful about saying I'm a
libertarian I think there is there is
room for good government do we do we
bring a copy in my book this guy needs
my book I'm gonna read it but this is a
piece of it I don't know you'll have
like 90 in your car you might have one
okay yeah bring watts or I'll send you
guys the audible copy or whatever but
this is literally what my book is about
because I agree conservatives got all
the big arguments right they got all the
big stuff right now I happen to be I
always say I'm for grudgingly pro-choice
so twelve weeks would be my cutoff
there's no room for you in the
Democratic Party with that position roof
they will not have you they want
eight-month abortions or you're out they
want literally ponies Martha born on
this tough that's nice it isn't a baby
that can live on its own without of
course by the way they can live they can
live on their own sometimes at 21 weeks
I mean there's all sorts of new evidence
in a very difficult argument it's I'm
not comfortable with it at all yeah what
approach I mean I'm not comfortable with
bortion and I don't think anybody has
including people to have abortions I
just I just can't tell a woman what to
do with their body but then you get into
these things of well what are we talking
about the last trimester I see yeah
you're making it I mean you'll you'll
dig my book this is the point is that
the conservatives basically got the big
stuff right and what you're asking for I
think is that is actually the future of
American politics the center is going to
move right so the center now the left
bananas they dragged us all into all
this craziness everyone that has seized
it for its lunacy Newsom and Cali
crumbling and New York crumbling the
same places will be the red state but
guys like you and and I think most sane
people will want those red states to not
just be like like you have to be super
religious or absolutely pro-life or
whatever and that's what I think the
future is there's going to be a move to
the center right and it will be let
basically like libertarians and
conservatives and I would say some
old-school liberals that sort of sounds
like what you're saying you are that
will try to battle it out and though so
you want you want like a secular
conservatism it sounds like because
you're afraid to say if if you say
you're conservative people think you
have to be my Republican people
immediately think I should put women in
jail for having an abortion which I
don't right right I am willing to under
I'm really willing to say that even even
if you were to describe abortion as
ultimately murder because what that what
happens with technology is a fetus is
gonna be able to live on its own at the
point of conception eventually yeah I
mean we will have artificial artificial
wombs and stuff like that
I'm argument is we put a price on human
life every single day of course if you
really are that that if human life is
that sacred to you then lower the speed
limit to 15 miles an hour and and and
we'll save all the lives yeah I promise
and if you're caught drunk drinking and
driving you lose your license forever
and you're in jail forever if you want
to be draconian save lives we can do it
we're not gonna do that yeah a society
has to play that game so in my opinion
I'm willing to I'm willing to accept
that that it when I say I'm pro-choice
it comes with very uncomfortable
Mike this is you're gonna dig the book
or what I mean this is you're you're
making this rename you're making this
well well you know what's funny about
the title is that don't burn this book
it's not like I expected them to do Nazi
Germany 1941 throw it in bonfires but
there actually is a version of book
burning happening these you know sign
read it and underground trolls they're
all trying to assault our amazon reviews
and all the online retailers to crush
our reviews and all that stuff because
what is that when you burn a book why do
you burn a book you don't want the ideas
getting out there so why would you
overload Amazon with fake reviews
because you don't want people to buy the
book so it's like these guys are
literally proving the point what's the
those annotator do you not the engine is
hater
I'm guessing sushi soda yeah yeah that
would be nice because they would be much
less tech-savvy you know um I'm guessing
that it's it's this like 18 19 maybe
even 15 like it's this it's this
underground internet thing every time a
troll comes after me with one of these
crazy things I always think man all you
need to do is read Jordans book just get
your stuff in order and he will not be
walking around thinking that Dave Rubin
is the biggest evil on the planet you
might disagree with me on some of my
politics way stuff hi I'm Ty and I'll
read a book do something creative start
your own business porn would be more of
a less waste of time yeah watch plot
like stay like I'm sure I don't know you
that well but I'm sure you've never got
on a form or YouTube comment and hate on
somebody or never like never you don't
watched it now I don't associate with
anybody who's ever done that yeah anyone
who makes a good amount of money who's
ever done that but that's what I mean
about the purpose thing so why would you
read Jordans Burt book it's like get
some purpose actually the nicest things
that people have said to me about my
book is that it that it's a much more
simple version of Jordans book oh yes
Jordan Jordans this is a 30 year
clinical psychologist who's giving you
serious
he's historical and when and I think I
got some of that from through osmosis
with him and I was able to translate it
into just language that that we can all
understand and I've been around a lot of
these great people it's like it's like
Rogan you guys we all sit down with
these cool people and I think if you got
a your head roughly on straight if you
can incorporate some of those ideas into
your life then you have no excuses to be
purposeless and miserable and want to
burn the world down but but a lot of
people do yeah I'm gonna open book like
you two came in here and started
preaching about the Democrats stuff like
that probably pretty open to it not that
go fall that way but I'd be open some of
the positive ideals from it yeah if you
can find any I would love to see them
cuz I don't know I'm not they're all
gone so what you're asking for what you
want is JFK that's not what your country
can do for you ask what you can do for
your country but the ship has sailed
think about how reverse that is then
Bernie Bernie says this is the
government we can give you a ton of [ __ ]
and we're gonna keep giving it and it's
free and none of it makes sense it we're
gonna pick $15 minimum wage
but someone else might say 20 like it's
all bananas made-up stuff by a guy who's
literally never accomplished anything
I am more of a successful I have no
doubt that both of you are more
successful businessman than Bernie
Sanders ever was or will will be Amen
it's at the point I have no doubt in
your future you will be a more
successful businessman than Bernie
Sanders ever will be yeah Bernie has
never accomplished anything
but but think how reverse ask not what
your country can do for you ask what you
can do for country he was a Democrat he
was a liberal Democrat president who by
the way was also anti-war and for
cutting taxes he so if Bernie walked up
there and said that yeah he really did
that's all i thing but but if Bernie
walked on stage and said that they would
hang him it is the reverse of what
Bernie says so that was so when I say
there's nothing left on the left the
Democrats look Biden is their nominee
Biden has dementia I'm gonna destroy him
oh yeah well Trump's the only way Trump
doesn't and I think is is if we truly
enter because of Korona a collapse like
a systemic collapse of almost
unimaginable consequences you know
hitting there with the depression the
economy I know I don't think we really
are getting there but when you take
these Democratic governors who would
love to see the whole thing crashing and
our food chain collapse like the day
that you can't go to Ralph's or whatever
and get and get a burger now things
really start changing and and it's like
nobody wants to think about any of this
stuff but but I guess I think Trump wins
and Biden I'm not even sure Biden's
gonna be the nominee I mean he obviously
has cognitive spending a switch amount
and the rumors for the the New York City
Governor yeah I don't think it'll be for
Cuomo I think he's and so I think he's
got to have enough cause skeletons in
his closet his dad was also supposed to
run for president and it never happened
so who not to do it was honestly a shell
I think it could be Michelle I think it
could be Hillary Obama yes that they
that mayor's found that out yes they are
they are basically dragging Biden there
and they're praying that he doesn't have
a full-on mental collapse before that
but I guarantee you they're going to do
every
thing they can to make sure we can't
have debates because they don't they
don't want you Oh Biden going against
Trump in a debate I'd be a County
Central Roast yeah it'd be true roasting
him every along the campaign trail yeah
and there'd be memes and be highlights
and we'd all be laughing yeah you like
it vote for that guy they don't get made
fun of every [ __ ] I think they've
gotten T ballots they want they don't
want to debate so so look all this stuff
is conspiratorial at some level but it's
like how does this feel very
conspiratorial to you like it's like the
only thing I would say is the world is
on lockdown so there the entire world
has been practicing this draconian lock
well Sweden says hold my beer that's
true Brazil no but for the mother's
behavioural even doing this and so
France opened up today yeah so I'm not
ready to be so cynical I am I am willing
to say that the health apparatus saw a
new virus didn't know what to make of it
did realize we were not prepared that we
seem to be underprepared that we didn't
have the infrastructure and so we had to
kind of like lock down so that we didn't
get panic inundated they didn't know
yeah I'm willing to say I got you I'll
go with you on that we did it now you're
adding three more months you
[ __ ] without any explanation
you're not even getting up here making
your argument you're arbitrarily
deciding this and and I think this is
will be if it's up the valves I
shouldn't go all the way to your
vaccination [ __ ] himself well first off
there's no vaccinations we need to get
to herd vaccinations meaning or another
but so habit and antibodies and the rest
of it but it's oh but that's what I'm
saying we don't have trusted people I
mean think about it
Rogen himself is more trusted or or
thought of or more influential yeah
whether he knows everything he's talked
about or not or he has people all over
the map I'm not even making a commentary
on any of that stuff but like he is more
trusted than brian Stelter or Jim Acosta
or anyone's idea and clowns you say not
anymore Providence CNN yeah Fox News any
nuts
yeah well he's far more profitable than
them too I mean I mean that's also why
it's like we can do all this and it's
like they fear that business model too
and now they're all doing it out of
their kitchen so I also think that the
world is we're entering a new world like
we're watching all of those things
collapse if you're CNN right now and
you're looking at the numbers and you're
going wait a minute we normally have
Anderson Cooper in a freaking 5 million
dollar studio with 80 crew members all
the lights all the makeup all the
cameras blah blah blah now he's doing it
from you know his basement or whatever
it is we just cut the the costs about
you know nine hundred percent you know
it's like I think everything is about
teaching the Glitter did write twitter
twitter for the longest time has said
man where people are a little more
efficient when they're working for a
home they don't have to get to the
office they have kid thing and take care
of they were thinking about going that
way and then out during this quarantine
the the profits and everything's been
high everyone's been doing well and
worked so it might be they don't need an
office yeah they're out of it twenty
three billion dollar companies out of
Silicon Valley they announced that yo
can I ask you why is Twitter how many
people does Twitter employ and how is it
profitable that's twenty three billion
how does it make nobody know it's very
unclear how Twitter is profitable
there's no I never Stan I never see an
ad on on Twitter I'm verified so I don't
know if maybe the verified people don't
see ads or something but like I don't
know how they're making money we're 600
employees 4,600 employees that most of
them are basically devoted to just
making sure conservative voices aren't
seen it's so pretty sure that's like 80%
of the company the S&P 500 like jeff has
shown us Apple Microsoft Amazon Google
and and one other their five companies
that essentially make up half if you
were to make a circle of the US economy
they make up half the economy the unit
us it's they don't employ many people at
all
yeah but they they have the lion's share
and then everybody else has a tiny
sliver yeah I mean so we are moving that
Tesla with Elon must put his foot down I
can't size how powerful that was because
Tesla is the the biggest car
manufacturer in the United States the
only one left in California they make
more cars than BMW they sell more beamed
up is that right they sell BMW 3-series
so by him going hey we're gonna leave
and go to Texas that's when they're like
alright man
but we need more of that right like we
fight we need later man it's it but it's
also like we need
more public people willing to speak out
where is every that's already been
everyone's scared but but where that not
not our level people where like the one
voice like we don't have any trusted
voice that I asked is the only guy with
with his notoriety and his credibility
the only one from the jump going but
hashtag open America hashtag of free
America he's the only one and you know
he's taking some heat for it there are a
lot of smart people that I have talked
to have heard as well who will use the
expression I don't know yeah because
because it's some of them a lot of older
so so this is scary for people who are
60 and over justice sure and I think
that a lot of those people who are in
power who might be in favor of opening
up or it's not corona I'm afraid to call
banned sneeze to now I'm like [ __ ] what
I was like but I'm not Anna risk at
aghori so so hashtag vibrant hashtag
crazy virility but you know I don't know
not obese hashtag famous last words
yeah and you take over the show yeah man
I I I just I just am I'm really wonder
man I really wanna about where this is
gonna take us and there's a new world on
the horizon that is it I think we have
no idea what just happened something so
bananas happened that none of us can
even fathom how crazy it is what this
has done to the economy our families my
mom's 70 she has a respiratory thing
she's trapped in her house my sister and
her family has been living with my
parents they just moved out found
another house so they just they thought
they were gonna live in New York City
the rest of their lives they got out at
the beginning of lockdown and now
they're out I've had somebody living in
my family in New York City since like
1860 we were able to trace it back now
for the first time nobody in my family
lives in New York City like I think the
migration patterns the fact that you're
saying we got to staying you know
staying fight some people are like just
forget it I'm getting out of here at all
they don't want to work at home are you
happy with your wife or your husband or
trapped in a house with someone you hate
do you like your kids do you want a home
school I'm like the amount of stuff that
I think people are thinking about but
can't quite figure out how to talk about
it properly I think is is off the charts
I want to do drugs
and I'm not a drug guy got some good
stuff in my house and I've been thinking
like do these shrooms and I'm like I
don't know maybe this isn't the time to
do it I know man I've had them just
sitting there I [ __ ] have shroom
shroom chocolate and somebody gave me
when they gave me some chocolate they go
this is really good Molly I'm like I
haven't yeah for 25 to hang out with the
riffraff yeah friends you know this I
just don't want to do mushrooms and then
like right when you're peak and be like
oh man we're in lockdown like just like
when it all comes crashing at once like
what reality is that the last try to a
lot of people aren't gonna fight because
of unemployment I have some friends who
they're collecting unemployment and they
don't have to go to work 9:00 to 5:00 or
60 hour weeks and they're sitting pretty
so like we're good man we don't want to
change but that's also the Petersons
thing and that's why you have to worry
about authoritarian governments right
they'll give you just enough we're
entering a diaw cracy that's what it is
they'll give us just enough to sit in
cozy chairs and play video games and
watch porn and blah blah blah so that
our lives are just whittled we're in a
queer in basically half idiocracy or not
in it right now we're viewing towards
half idiocracy half Wally
remember Wally the the Disney movie like
that's where all your and we're we're
just gonna sit in chairs consume stuff
all the time and then there'll be this
other set of people who are out there
living their lives but I have a feeling
they're mostly gonna live in Texas I go
by property in Texas where zona
Arizona's booming is it yeah I kind of
live closer to water though a lot of
Arizona people are texting me like come
on come on we were there in like the
summer and I got out no remember I got
off and I went so that bus needs to turn
the [ __ ] off yeah I saw slowing in my
and Ryan goes that's the weather bump I
go it's 9 p.m. who knows well if it was
12 a.m. it was yeah but then they go
into dry heat and you're like alright
alright you tell me this is dry but like
that man spontaneously combusted you
know it is a somber time in in August
and enjoy yeah sign up it's so hot to
sign me up yeah beside me up
the other good thing right so you get
out of there for the summer yeah yeah
exactly the other some of those thing is
being comics I haven't this the most I
mean I get offers but I've gotten so
many more offers from states that are
open because a lot of comics are scared
to tour yeah and they hear me talk about
on here on Rogan how I'm like dude I'm
not scared of Cronus send me out there
so we get all these offers so now that
Houston already alright when a day's two
days we still haunting saw in the day
and then spoke in a we just added shows
that's awesome I'm really glad here
that's my whole tour got cancelled and I
was just talking to the Live Nation guys
and there and I basically said can I go
to Texas and they're like yeah if you
want to do it so I actually didn't know
anyone started booking stuff it's half
complete free yes yeah but you can just
add motion you're getting more and more
up until this cover thing I would
imagine your popularity and being able
to go and speak was oh yeah I had I mean
I had weeks worth of stuff and then this
whole month I had like you a maybe just
met Brooke right oh yeah yeah wait a
minute Justin's booking you in Houston I
just I spoke to Ari yesterday yeah yeah
I'm sorry you booked in Houston no but
he told me if I want to if I want to get
out there we can we can make some stuff
up you are you a sneaker head those
720's are you see heavy you just I I got
two pairs of this kind blistered I'm not
I'm not like a huge sneaker alright it
took a lot of us got one strike it took
a lot to get this bubble I was like can
I be one of those bubble guys you can do
and I see the bubble boy but yeah here
we are and you're that smart
give me the bulb you know Travis Scott
this the whole world is changing so
crazy my son is obsessed with the [ __ ]
is it for tonight oh yeah Scott's
character you got to get him off that
thing
my son's a man I do already have it's so
bad they broke his they broke his album
where my son had to go into a land in
fortnight and and into an area
there was a state and Travis Scott was
there singer huh
my son was like the coolest [ __ ]
thing I'm like God ideal yeah but okay
so am I am i is that is that am i know
whatever you're about to say no you're
not crazy you're not like oh my god is
so crazy
yeah listen we're in half I'm gonna give
you three halves that's how messed up
this thing is we're in half idiocracy
half Wally and half matrix what black
mayor up sowed oh well the whole thing
is black mirror for the word the most
boring episode of all time which one
black bear the most boring episode of
black bear just talking about black
mirror that's funny no but we're in
we're in half that and then half the
matrix because if you remember the
matrix the whole purpose beyond the the
red pill blue pill thing that became the
meme is that humans will just be the
batteries for the digital world so when
you said your son does that it's like if
he starts spending more than twelve
hours and one second on that game which
by the way plenty of people do then your
organic body is just the battery for the
digital world that was literally was the
point and that and then we can get into
some simulation or in the simulation
yeah that's what they'll slit my wrists
yeah I know well listen Dave is that how
this ends renin offs himself but yeah
bookies don't burn Michael phone feed
the dog would you exactly don't burn
this book yeah if you give you guys a
copy I just draw miss you man yes I
promise you guys you will love it and
and it's this it's exactly fighting you
want to see something messed up go to if
you go to the Amazon page so you can see
all reviews what these losers are doing
but it doesn't matter you're bigger than
the remote I know again again this is
this is my thing with reviews and I yeah
have you I've never bought a book rented
a movie I went to stamp show based off
reviews you know you don't care what a
person who you never met a crap way
across the world said about so I'm never
looking at a yelp review I'm at rest
I don't know that Brian don't say this
restaurants great I know Brian I'm gonna
go this yeah I don't go well dude 1/2
stars Brian I don't know all these
people have no [ __ ] clue about gave
it 1/2 stars
somebody said the mushrooms at that
restaurant [ __ ] I can't go there
dude you have 50 this is how you know
it's weird you have 52% 5 stars 42% yeah
stars well that's it so say you got you
guys know Scott Adams the creator of
Dilbert the comic strip I know he's a
really interesting guy and he he said to
me I'm calling it a Scott Adams theory
if you have splits on your book 5 and 1
he said that's how you know you have a
hit yes because you've got people who
love you and then you got you just got
the hate well it's gonna be great then
guys it was nice I can't wait oh yeah
you're the best this is why you're great
yeah yeah well you guys got to come on
my show and we'll talk you know well
here who's your last question and then
you get out of here who's your most
impressive guest who's the guy that you
I mean Peterson he changed my life yeah
he sighs it's the easy answer I know you
know what I'll tell you you know I love
having comics on of course but you know
the thing is with comics it's like comic
you barely need the interviewer it's
like the comic you could just sit them
down and they can just go yeah but I'll
tell you when I had Richard Lewis on and
he's totally apolitical that doesn't but
I remember seeing his HBO his HBO young
comic special from like 1983
it's his TV debut it's Seinfeld's TV
debut Bob Nelson's on there it's like a
it's an all-star kay I think well harry
Anderson's on it and I've just loved him
from that like I saw that I was like 7
years old or something and I loved him
through curb and everything else and you
watch that special and it's like
Seinfeld's up there telling jokes and
it's all good but he does something
Richard Lewis at his peak like before
all the drugs and everything it's it's
it's perfection it's art it's like Usher
and anyway so I interviewed him and then
as we were saying goodbye my Studios at
my house and you know he's a big
germaphobe like Larry David and all the
there's a lot of comics that are that
are germaphobe I'm not I can tell you're
not but as we were saying goodbye he
goes he walks up to me and I thought he
was gonna shake my hand but I was ready
to do a fist bump because that's what he
does with Larry on the show all the time
because they don't shake hands and I put
my hand out and he put it down and he
put his hand on my face and he goes he
goes dick hey we made out I made our
Richard
that's actually the day Khurana started
because they know he put his hand on my
face and he goes he goes you're a
wonderful interviewer Wow
and I was like little Dave when he was
12 like if he had heard that from
Richard Lewis would be pretty that's
like full circle yeah that's where you
come all the way around so now I'm gonna
touch your guy's face that's not what
you do dip it in covet first place
please Will Sasso the comedian and actor
said I'm gonna dip my hands and Cove it
and come over and beat the [ __ ] do a
picture let's do a picture right here
it's right here I enjoyed that man so
did I it was great and read what you
just told me just really quickly about
this is kind of interesting so one would
say it's the most interesting yeah
people won't you should stop your
[ __ ] looks do hey mainstream media
why aren't you talking about this read
it pregnant yeah Bryan suck my [ __ ] no
yeah dude suck it that's what you texted
me this morning but that's not what I
want all right this is at Clay Travis to
view if you fall play droughts on social
media especially Twitter he was hard in
the paint on positive things with Corona
so if you're looking for something
that's so doom and gloom he's your
follow he but it has now been 19 days
since Georgia's governor opened up the
state the media assured us everyone
would die what have the results shown
the exact opposite cases death and
hospitalizations have all plummeted
official data he posts it
he was the success all around a Florida
taxes Tennessee Georgia and Oklahoma
since reopening their state's is why the
stories about all five states and their
governors have almost completely
disappeared from the national media why
is that why is that hmm and here's the
thing he's right on this if things were
going bad in any of these states there
would be live reports every 10 minutes
but the trains going well crickets
crickets what are we what the [ __ ] are
we doing man
how crazy is that we think that [ __ ]
chance I think it's dope it's nuts hey
chin it's literally not for a second I
don't like that
like in his face thank you I'm getting
this you know what dude nah you're going
nice going down and that's why I'm not
wearing that thing yeah especially
around you guys but Jen how crazy is it
that these the five states that open up
everyone [ __ ] gave all the governor's
[ __ ] and they're like oh yeah all this
gonna result in more deaths more
hospitalizations more cases long and
it's way down but everybody's dead in
Sweden right are they dead and sweeter
sure not Bryan all right but it puts
Sweden's population by the way eight
eight million a little swollen come for
it but the thing is is if you look at
the five states that open why went every
state go well they're doing pretty good
with that we have legit CDC that counts
right what we did we did also wear a
mask a bunch of people for a very long
time and then yeah we'd done our drop
yeah they'll be glad in the coast we
will stop doing it curve crush the curve
and so now we're [ __ ] I've been
waiting for this huge epidemic I've been
waiting for all the bodies we we did it
and you want to extend three more months
I've never been about shutting places
down I didn't want that at all every
whatever as far as I need to see your
credentials
why are you sure your real name is
Cheney wearing masks to help you know
just prevent or try my best to prevent
me white yeah me from spray someone else
I thought that was a nice thing to do so
I don't what Brian know what Brides like
he saw a guy on a street and he's like a
[ __ ] I'm like do you got it all wrong
he's wearing it so he doesn't that's
right it to other people that's true I
have a baby that's why I was doing it I
have a bad attitude about masks hashtag
maskless yeah you know whatever
hashtag maskless let's make masks but
the mouth part is really open I mean
it's the same thing this like this have
like really no like you know your girls
wear those beacons worth just just the
lips are covered
let's make massage' you wanna make a
song man yeah let's make a song that is
the Crocs was mask just looking you look
like a blow-up doll no no we're making
our shoelace you just put it here in
here that's a great it's gonna it's
gonna do the exact same thing dude let's
[ __ ] create masks bang bang it would
look kind of racist to use racist when I
think about old cartoons it reminds you
that's kind of John man I'm talking
about
I'm not black well make sure the masks
are Bluffton all right no chit know
brands not paying the rest of face black
gotcha
everybody okay so I don't know if you
guys still want to talk about this
because you guys already went kind of
in-depth with the extension so you know
at the airport we're gonna have to wear
masks but once you're on the plane you
don't have to win
yeah airlines don't times the opposite
no in any airport they can deny you
access to the flight if you don't have a
mask on you're welcome cheap so you
gotta wear masks and then when you get
on the plane they don't enforce the
rules but they advisory will encourage
you to do it yeah so on though you know
I'm doing I'm thinking that when I
implant through myself and pop and
peanuts and getting real loud on me like
that transgender is function just ah red
scarf [ __ ] what else you gonna peanuts
so let's say you're in a business class
and there's a kid all the way in the
back that's allergic to peanuts would
you not eat peanuts if yeah I would not
I would not ever want to put a child
that's good to hear that's good to hear
I don't think you know what they don't
get peanuts anymore look I'm elated you
know when we talk about freedom I'm not
talking about trampling other people's
rights or making other people sick
that's not what I'm talking about
yah-tchi I don't I don't buy or believe
that that this is what you believe in
the Constitution yeah
what is this what would pretty much be
si now all right moving on okay let's do
a weird one so there was a video that
was going viral because there was a
Chinese woman in Ikea she was walking
around with like a dress shirt and that
she starts masturbating around like
different parts of the store on our
nature we don't know why I plan used to
faced-off of the people in the
background it seems like the video was
taken before the pandemic happened and
so this must be somewhat old but China
actually went out of their way found the
video and try to scrub it as best as
they could from the internet was this in
China actually in China by missing
though it was injured the location is
not specified she's not bad but yeah
she's just walking around recording
herself masturbating [ __ ] in IKEA I hate
IKEA stresses me out that's kind
I have to be out she's pretty hot that's
kind of that Margaret out no that's hot
I'm sorry I'm such a [ __ ] there's
something about her sitting on that
couch right that picture to me is not
unsexy I just have to be honest there's
nothing thanks about IQ but she's gonna
figure this out something about the
square cheap furniture and masturbation
I guess I don't know what it is we buy a
cocktail for my cue seven thousand Oh
put that piece to stick put those pieces
together with your friend and then rub
one out ah
these are furniture doesn't stain well
this she didn't wet spots are not
approached she goes missing though
unless you got well that's all I could
find
okay I got some I check this side this
is kind of messed up I don't know how to
feel about this so Takashi 6-9 wanted to
donate two hundred thousand dollars for
hungry kids and it says no kid hungry is
a foundation and they declined his offer
because they don't want to be associated
with Oh so you so you guys gonna make up
to two hundred thousand dollars he's
giving the kids you right so what do you
do there you [ __ ] take the money take
the money he did this money yeah man
especially with kids yep know what take
you he's a snitch it doesn't all line
with their values he doesn't but they
don't say exact things obviously he's a
snitch and he was part of gangs and yeah
alright okay maybe they don't need it
maybe they don't need the money
yeah maybe they're good yeah man there
are some like crazy ones but I think
they might be able to aggressive relish
you guys want to watch it police beating
stuff no okay
this is all so bad but these are
pictures from the incident from your
tattoo artist oh yeah
so that's his car and there's a tree
right there I thought okay
there's no front-end damage but you can
see the side is what went into the tree
and that's how the YouTube story was
killed can't drink and drive you can't
drink and drive you can't drink and
drive
oh well I think it's important to at
least look at it see you see what a bad
decision yeah just be incredibly close
life has changed forever forever it's a
bad spell something that he lost a
friend
that's the part how can you get over
that this is not a bad kid no no you
made a mistake this is an artist Jung
made a huge mistake that's a shame
yeah Wow yeah that's very sad
this I thought was amazing this dog was
left in a ditch and had it like messed
up ankles on I think both of his left
sides his incus got affected so he had
to be amputated so someone rescued him
and look at how this guy can actually
walk they're both right legs and he
plays around with other dogs too
that's impressive super yeah I would put
a dog down but but that's some people
got cancer they're like you can put it
on chemotherapy no he's not doing that
putting him dog that he's thriving I
know is this one right in the one left
or the same size that's why it's good
good for that dog that's an athletic dog
planes pretty healthy besides the two
legs yeah I just don't believe it till I
get dogs that's me yeah no I I think
it's amazing I love dogs
it's incredible how they can find out a
walk that way little guys yeah dogs are
so resilient he's a great know yeah I
[ __ ] love them to us what's not to
love about dogs get that little two legs
I'm not gonna do that
see I'm not the guy that goes and gets
the dog that's in the pound that's all
no and I and I appreciate people to do I
love my gut I want a dog that's I want
them honey
yeah need four legs I need I need a
certain age I'm an ageist I'm not
getting a six-year-old son but that's
all I'm a dick one last one this is not
that current but it's so awesome to
watch just to get outside stuff you saw
is already haven't seen this oh man it's
got a refreshing I'm sure what's going
on with this dog it's stuck on a curtain
something like a curtain in the backyard
like its tail looks like it's stuck this
awesome cop the cop killer more else
where's chilli see
we're just gonna cut it just read a bit
though of course not
[Music]
make you do without the soundtrack that
yeah but then it's alright
he's just scared right now yes oh we got
happy I know listen the music yep it's
still yeah he's still freaking out watch
this part
oh he's like thanks dude all right i'll
sui's at their dogs all thanks dogs are
the best yeah my my friend stepped on my
dog's paw we were there were these girls
right my one buddy's really smart oh
he's a pro rock climbers it's the
[ __ ] big muscular handsome guy and
we're with these curls smells with young
man and then my friend steps on my dog
spot my dog he's a puppy
oh like that same thing just a complete
baby and he grabs the dog and he just
goes like this he just goes I got you I
got you
he's cradling the dog and the girls like
he's all muscular yep you know it was
how we did that then you know sometimes
in life things take you for a turn
football meaning you know the guy
everything's moving forward and then
what happens is a crow flies through
your window and hit you she cage like
have a [ __ ] did that happen I was having
a great day you guys don't know what
we're talking about for Brendan and I do
and so just Ginny cat well boys
sometimes Hairston but that's sold out
we're gonna add some shows that's some
shows spoke infamies end of June Brian
will also be there that thing's almost
sold out in shows and then July 17 18th
we're trying to add a sixteenth those
tickets in Salt Lake City at wise guys
will also be on sale yep yeah but in the
road brother let's do it I love it mask
mask Aeschylus mask a mask list or dude
the mask
this the pirated we're out